[Music]
apparently coming up with new lists of
things day after day is difficult and
I'm starting to worry that BuzzFeed is
beginning to lose steam yeah you see
you're gonna see what I mean with this
little piece that we call BuzzFeed's
running out of lists yeah these are real
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently here's one 31 coffee stains
that almost look like West Virginia as
the first one yeah looks actually a lot
like West Virginia 43 white people who
claim they saw 12 years a slave unless
we care about I don't know look at this
one 17 guys who looked nothing like
Jason Statham what his 127 epic spackle
fails oh boy that guy looks sad here's
one 32 photos of napping dictators that
will warm your heart
isn't he adorable there's nothing wrong
with that nothing wrong with that I
watched that one here's one 16
spider-man villains who might have
asthma here's 7 warning signs that you
are Joe Biden yeah 9 sex positions you
can do while wearing earbuds Wow why did
they take that away so quick because if
I was enjoying looking at it
that's the foul ball souvenir lien
thanks for reading that out loud and or
no problem it'll go over well with the
Turner gang hey how about this one
twelve dream homes photograph from too
far away nineteen anti-gay Republican
politicians who totally look gay
seventeen things you didn't know about G
tripplehorns nephew thirty-two pictures
of your coworker Jen explaining a plot
line from Castle Wow she's really into
it yeah Castle look at this eleven
recipes you can make in a prison toilet
oh come on that looks very that looks
delicious
I would eat that and finally fourteen
things we'll bet you didn't know you
could fit inside you boy that's quality
stuff that's what that is